what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with curse of the White Knight
now if you're looking to catch up on
everything that we've done make sure you
guys check the link down in the
description that'll send you to the
playlist which will get you caught up on
everything we've covered so far but in
effect in the last video that we did we
basically found out that Bruce Wayne is
not actually a Wayne that instead what
had happened is that in the early days
of Gotham City you had bakar and you had
Edmond Wayne and bakar was more or less
like a religious fanatic but he had
killed Edmund Wayne and then stolen his
identity so the reality here is that
from a DNA perspective Bruce Wayne's not
a Wayne and he never was his parents
aren't Lanes none of them are Wayne's
it's literally a stolen identity the
person who's actually descended from
Edmund Wayne is Jean-Paul Valley who's
basically Azrael he's a character that
even now he's a little bit of a mystery
in curse of the White Knight but the
cool thing about this is that what it
does is it initially picks up with
Harley Quinn now remember one of the
things that Harley Quinn establishes
here is that she and Jack Napier had
basically figured out what was going on
right her and the Joker had figured out
that Bruce Wayne is not a Wayne but when
Jack Napier was cured quote unquote and
turned into a regular human right
basically lost the influence of the
Joker temporarily they agreed not to
tell Bruce that Bruce needs to figure it
out on his own and the reason why is
because if they told him he's not a
Wayne Then Bruce Wayne would have
figured in some capacity that joker
Persona was basically coming back to
Jack Napier and he was going insane
making up with a bunch of nonsense but
by whatever Manner and whatever means
Bruce Wayne probably wouldn't have
believed them but by figuring it out on
his own it's incontrovertible there is
no influence there it's literally him
discovering the story as it's truly been
told and that's kind of the ironic thing
is that opposed to looking at Harley
Quinn as a betrayer he actually looks at
it from the perspective of okay that
kind of makes sense but the reality here
is there's much bigger things going on
here one of the things that we've
learned in curse of the White Knight is
that one of the reasons why Gotham sucks
so bad is you have like the Elites right
the ultra wealthy who are doing things
like making life hard for people in the
middle or the lower class keeping them
below a certain economic threshold so
they can never really move up
financially things along those lines
right in a lot of ways keeping people in
the city of Gotham in a state of almost
consistent destitution and poverty Bruce
Wayne also figured out that he's
actually a contributor to everything
that's going on with the elites he's one
of them and when Harley Quinn asked the
question how could you possibly not know
that's the case like how could you not
know that you're a person who
contributes to these ultra wealthy
people the response of Bruce Wayne is I
there was no way to know I spend my
nights basically beating up criminals
and I spend my days combing over crime
scenes and looking over documentation I
have a very very small role in what goes
on with the money that I have and so on
and so forth I trust other people to
take care of that for me and so right
wrong or otherwise he is literally part
of the problem he just simply didn't
know it and that's the irony behind
curse of the White Knight is what Sean
Murphy is really done here over the
course of the original story and then
this story as he's established this idea
that where we under normal circumstances
look at Bruce Wayne in the main DC
Universe as a guy who uses his wealth
and his resources to try to help make
the city of Gotham better in this
universe he's largely derelict in that
he doesn't really focus on using his
money to improve the lives of the people
in Gotham his money is just a means to
an end so it really kind of becomes an
answer to the question what happens when
you have a person worth potentially
hundreds of billions of dollars that
never pays attention to where their
money's going and only focuses on that
income so long as it helps them achieve
their goal of being a vigilante it's how
his role and his money was able to be
manipulated is how Jack Napier was able
to spend the idea that Batman is
actually more of a problem for the city
of Gotham than anything else and that's
one of the things that he hits at here
in his conversation with Harley Quinn he
comes to this realization Batman really
is a problem for the city of Gotham the
truth about this is that me pummeling
criminals beating him up in the middle
of the night sure there are people who
do this because they're inherently bad
people and they do bad things but there
are also people who do it out of
desperation but the truth about this is
that my dereliction to how my money was
being spent and in effect chasing a
problem that I am helping to contribute
to that's an issue so Gotham City
doesn't need Batman Gotham City needs
Bruce Wayne and so that's the cool thing
is because what he does is he basically
puts out this idea he intends to abandon
the role he intends to walk away from
being Batman right Batman will die and
Bruce Wayne will live that's the cool
thing about this is because following
that of course he goes to visit Barbara
Gordon he doesn't really tell her
anything they didn't tell Harley Quinn
right Barbara Gordon is she's really not
as well informed about the whole Edmund
Wayne and bakara that whole situation he
fills her in on that but he essentially
tells her I intend to leave I intend to
vacate and so while the city of Gotham
is on the hunt for Jean-Paul Valley who
killed all those different criminals in
Arkham Asylum who's taken out cops who
killed Commissioner Gordon right he's a
vigilante Batman by all Sanders a
measurement where that whole that this
whole thing is being done by the cops
and they literally launched a kind kind
of announcement to the city of Gotham
that's more or less if you see something
say something Batman interrupts it all
right and he makes this just kind of
amazing speech here right check this out
he says for decades it's been my honor
to serve you fighting crimes saving
lives trying to make this a better place
but I knew it couldn't go on forever
it's clear to me now that the era of
Batman must come to an end wearing this
cape was a simple idea born in a simpler
time at first I just wanted to help
catch the bad guys but over the years
things have gotten more complicated it's
no longer a childish game of cops and
robbers it's serial killers monsters and
super criminals when I started out all I
needed to catch them was a rope in
handcuffs but now I'm a one-man Army who
does as much damage to you as I do to
them I used to be a hero from the golden
age but now I'm a villain and that's why
Jack Napier beat me by saying what I was
afraid to admit that's why I'm
supporting the Napier initial initiative
being Batman means being whatever Gotham
needs me to be and what you all need now
is to know the truth that Batman is
really Bruce Wayne he dumps his identity
out there for the entire city of Gotham
right he says I've recently learned that
the Wayne Empire has been hijacked by
those who have corrupted Gotham the most
by the elites which makes me complicit
in their crimes which makes me even more
responsible for criminals like Joker and
asriel that's why I'm giving it all away
to destroy the elites and give Gotham
back to the people my fortune doesn't
belong to me it belongs to you Wayne
Corp and all of its subsidiaries will be
dissolved my entire inheritance will be
put into a non-profit that will create
better schools libraries homeless
shelters and scholarships everything we
generate will be donated right back to
Gotham offsetting your taxes for decades
Gotham will no longer be a city of
Darkness it'll be a city of light it
will be a place without Shadows a place
without Batman but first I need a favor
asriel's still out there as soon as the
sun goes down he'll make his move I can
get him but I don't want anybody else
getting hurt that's why I'm asking all
of you to stay off the streets until I
can catch him I'm asking for your
forgiveness I'm asking you to trust me
I'm asking for your permission to be
Batman one last time now this is a huge
moment in the Batman Mythos and what's
so amazing about this about what Sean
Murphy's doing here he's quite literally
mirroring DC Comics right if you guys
ever had a chance and you've seen Alex
Ross art and I've got it all throughout
my basement that Alex Ross's art is
called photorealism but it kind of gives
you a feeling of a time when superheroes
walked a little taller right there was
no moral ambiguity like there was a
complete and total differentiation
between the good guys and the bad guys
the good guys fought the bad guys and
the good guys beat the bad guys and and
that was it it was just that clear-cut
and simple that's what he talks about
when he talks about the golden age right
it's Sean Murphy saying like back in the
40s and 50s and and 60s it was that
clear-cut it was simple back in the 40s
maybe not so much because Batman did
kill people but like from the 1950s
going forward it was a much cleaner and
simpler time when it came to superheroes
it wasn't until the 70s with like the
death of Gwen Stacy in in Marvel Comics
and the 1980s when you got uh when you
got Dark Knight Returns that Comics
became a lot more murky the line between
superheroes and super villains became
murkier right the rise of the anti-hero
different things like that that it was
it was a more complicated time not only
that Batman's role really has changed
you look at the old Comics back in like
the 1940s 1950s when it came to Batman
it really was just him with like a
roping handcuffs and that was basically
it a great example of this is the story
Batman war on crime from world's
greatest superheroes by Paul deeney and
Alex Ross we covered that story again
we'll have the link down in the
description as well if you want to see
it beautifully written story beautifully
drawn story that's that's what that was
it was Batman with a roping handcuffs no
over complication no advanced technology
or anything like that but his time has
gone by and as things have become more
advanced criminals have become more
capable in terms of hiding their actions
they've become more dangerous they've
become more extreme that Batman had to
slowly match them he had to kind of keep
up with him and the reality of this is
that while that was necessary for him to
maintain his role otherwise trying to
beat someone like the Joker who's
flooding the city of Gotham with toxin
using a rope at handcuffs would
basically make Batman inept the reality
of this is that the people of Gotham
were caught in the middle collateral
damage their homes were destroyed their
lives were destroyed in an effort for
Batman to keep up and to keep things
going and so realizing what it was that
Jack Napier said in the first Batman the
White Knight comic where he said Batman
contributes to the poverty and
destitution of Gotham and we become
criminals because we feel like we have
no other choice because we have families
to feed right or enacted desperate
operation or whatever the case happens
to be right people prey on others not so
much because they're horrible but
because they're desperate because Batman
does nothing to improve the financial
situation and to solve the underlying
issue of desperation in the city of
Gotham Batman's the problem right Batman
creates people like me right that's what
Jack Napier said he turns guys like me
from Ordinary People Into The Joker
that's why that happens and so realizing
that everything Jack Napier said was
true the most capable way for Batman to
protect the city of Gotham is to
literally give all his money away to do
that exact thing and so what ends up
happening is that because of the fact
that Jean-Paul Valley had previously
attacked the bat cave and taken out most
everything that Batman had at his
disposal he has to go Lo-Fi he's got one
Batmobile left and it's the OG Batmobile
right it's like the Batman 89 Batmobile
right like the old Michael Keaton movie
Batmobile and it looks dope I'm gonna be
honest with you guys I really hope that
with James Gunn's new DC films Universe
whatever it is he's doing I hope we get
the old school Batmobile back from like
batman89 I hope that returns because
that thing is amazing I just love the
way that thing looks but it's one of
those the one of those murky situations
because Bruce Wayne looking at this
whole situation with Azrael comes to a
stark realization one of them's gotta go
right like asriel is he's a Believer
right like this guy is a religious
fanatic right this guy believes that
what he's doing is legitimately right
that it's the way to go and so as a
result of this because asriel has no
qualms with killing the only way for
Batman to deal with him is to kill him
and the crazy thing about this is
literally every member of the Batman
family tells him not to Nightwing tells
him not to Barbara Gordon tells him not
to they all tell him you can't do this
Batman doesn't kill but the reality here
is that Bruce Wayne seems to have come
to this realization that while it is
true that Batman doesn't necessarily
kill there are times when he has to
because there are some threats out there
that are so extreme that it's like
Alfred said in in the Dark Knight right
that there are so many people out there
who aren't looking for anything like
money right they can't be bought bullied
or reasoned with then some people just
want to watch the world burn and the
only way to deal with them is to
eliminate them it's the only thing that
you can possibly do and so of course
Batman getting out to Gotham City comes
to this realization the people in Gotham
do trust him they've cleared the streets
in its entirety now whether or not this
is due to the people of Gotham actually
trusting Batman or it's due to a manner
of self-preservation is debatable but
Sean Murphy gives us this perspective
that like people trust Batman and that's
the reason why they've cleared the
streets and so Batman's basically given
the location of Jean-Paul Valley and he
ultimately tracks him down while the
Gotham City Police Department does
respond as well and it's really more of
them trying to find a way to eliminate
Azrael before Batman can quote unquote
fall down the path and kill Azrael
Batman takes their vehicles out and kind
of returns it back to this idea of it
being him and John Paul Valley and so
there's one point there's like amazing
moment here when Batman really like his
car is destroyed effectively by John
Paul Valley he takes out a plane in the
process which is kind of cool and he
just like emerges from the Batmobile
with like an automatic rifle and it
looks amazing like I gotta say man I
kind of want like I'm gonna hit up Sean
Murphy on Twitter because I don't know
if if Matt Hollingsworth drew it or if
Sean Murphy was the one who drew it I
think Matt Hollingsworth did I'm gonna
hit him up and be like hey man is there
any way for you to like get this to me
as like a full page thing like I'll pay
for it man like of course I would right
it's your time right like I will pay for
that but like I kind of want this as
like just a full comic panel like a full
comic page send that to me as like a
work of art and it would be amazing
because I would frame that because it is
dope but like the fight between the two
is really really interesting because
what goes on here is Jean-Paul Valley
calls out Batman instantly right he
calls him out in a moment and he says
for all your talk and all your Glitz and
glamor right all the shows you put on
about how you don't kill and how you're
better is Gotham City really better off
with you in it but it's the same
argument that Jack Napier made right
have you you made Gotham a better place
more so than that like at the end of the
day we're not different you and I right
he says you travel the world seeking
something bigger than yourself something
that would repair you bring you peace
but you learned that there is no peace
for someone like you there's only war
and as you look back at the blood in
your wake you realize you've become too
accepting of your demons that you've
lost your soul so you tried to save
yourself by reaching out to those around
you but they couldn't save you either
because your War had become their War
now here you are all alone trying to be
a martyr in a battle that killed you a
long time ago and that's what's like
that perfectly encapsulates this battle
between Jean-Paul Valley and Bruce Wayne
because literally as reality is just
like you're dead like Bruce Wayne is
dead Bruce Wayne is gone you make this
Grand speech to the city of Gotham and
you tell people like I'm gonna give all
my money away and all that kind of stuff
like it will somehow absolve you but at
the end of the day you made Gotham this
sway so you can't you can't create a
problem and then say I want to fix the
problem and then expect the world to Pat
you on the back right it doesn't work
that way this war right you Batman your
war on crime everything that makes you
who you are since the death of your
parents it's long since killed you and
whether you kill me or you imprison me
or you give away your hundreds of
billions of dollars it will not change
any of that you will still be the man
that broke the city of Gotham and is now
trying to quote unquote fix it for no
other reason than the fact that it will
soothe your guilty conscience Bruce
Wayne it's just this amazing moment
between the two because as Bruce Wayne
is hell-bent on killing John Paul Valley
eventually Nightwing shows up and the
crazy thing about this is that there's
this amazing moment between the two
where you kind of have this whole
situation where Batman kind of seems
hopeless right he's just like everything
I've done has made the city of Gotham
worse the city of Gotham doesn't need me
or even Bruce Wayne if I die fighting
Jean-Paul Valley this city is all the
better for it right it's why he intended
in handing himself over to the cops
right turning himself in and saying like
I've operated as vigilante for all these
years you know I'm not above the law
therefore I should be subject to the law
that kind of thing but Nightwing's whole
stance here is you don't understand you
have this belief that because of the
fact that you screwed up right because
of the fact that Batman or Bruce Wayne
Wayne Corp or whatever because it's
contributed to the collapse of Gotham
City that you've somehow made the city
worse in its entirety but the the
statements was John Paul Valley or the
ramblings of a Madman right this guy's
just babbling on about things he doesn't
understand anything about the reality
here is sure you could have used your
hundreds of billions of dollars to make
Gotham better and so on and so forth but
you did the best you could with what you
had right you were suffering and you
were struggling and you were in pain and
your parents were dead and you wanted to
find some semblance of meaning there
Gotham City is not as perfect as it
could be right it's not this amazing
just incredible place it's not a light
of the world but it is better than what
it was right what would Gotham City look
like Batman if you didn't exist right
like if if you weren't here what would
Gotham City look like and to a degree
it's one of those things where Batman
doesn't necessarily seem to want to
listen right he's so hell-bent on his
mission that at the end of the day it's
like that guy's gotta go he's Gotta Die
and if I die in the process that's fine
and so what's amazing about this is that
Batman kind of has a second Showdown
with Jean-Paul Valley right runs it to
him yet again and the funny thing about
this is that Batman kind of is uh you
know realizing what's going on and it is
a kind of fight to the death that he
wants to go down swinging right wants to
go down his way and so he brings like
these two rapiers now here's the
important thing behind this we didn't
necessarily cover this the reason why
Batman does this is because at the
beginning of the story or the beginning
of this video really like this one part
that when his parents had been killed
that he was actually crying to Alfred
and he said the reason why they died is
because he wanted to go see Zorro and
the reason why he wanted to go see Zorro
is because his dad said he could he
couldn't play with the swords because
they would hurt him and that by watching
Zorro he could learn how to use swords
so that he could play with him and that
he wouldn't hurt himself right and and
that because that whole situation from a
child's perspective that's why his
parents die now the reality is that's
not the case right you know that and I
know that and Bruce Wayne as an adult
knows that but when you're a little kid
your brain has a way of trying to
rationalize things as best it can and
oftentimes blaming yourself for when
things go wrong and so as a result of
that Alfred had there was kind of this
really beautiful moment where Alfred
said okay so I'll make a deal with you
Bruce Wayne if you can put on your your
suit and you can go to the funeral for
your parents when we get back I will
teach you how to use those rapiers so
you will become just as capable as Zorro
so that if you're ever in danger or
anybody that you care about is ever in
danger that you'll know how to use these
swords and you'll know how to protect
you and yours and so that kind of set
the seeds for Batman kind of becoming
Batman right the things that he did but
it was a really really beautiful and
touching moment but that's why he
brought these swords here right because
it's kind of a throwback to that early
bit of a discussion now the funny thing
here is that asriel's still using all
his Advanced Armament the high-tech
Batman suit and so on and so forth and
so what Bruce Wayne says is like I saw
the inscription that was written on your
on your your Rapier right your scout on
your sword right and what it said is
like God's will basically you know so
here's the question that I have for you
if this is truly a fight between you and
me and this fight is truly God's will
then why don't we have this fight as two
men fighting based on what God wants and
so at that point Jean-Paul Valley is
like touche so we cast aside all this
technology and the like him and Batman
are just fighting on top of the
Batmobile out in the middle of like
Gotham Harbor right and so they've just
got swords and it's just bare knuckle
fighting and watching this knock down
drag out fight between Jean-Paul Valley
and Bruce Wayne is phenomenal because of
that history they have but also because
of the fact they're fighting over the
Wayne Legacy they're fighting over their
own history this is in a lot of ways a
modern day depiction of bakar vs Edmund
Wayne right from the old days back in
the early times of Gotham City that's
what it looks like and so Jean-Paul
Valley ever trying to play mind games
with Bruce Wayne he asked in this
question he says tell me one last thing
before all of this is over Bruce Wayne
do you think they knew and the response
of Bruce is like who are you talking
about he says your parents did they know
that they were swine draped in pearls
leeches feeding from the belly tit of
Gotham fake Aristocrats bred from a
rotten bloodline do you think they knew
and the reality here is basically
insulting Batman's family right
insulting his dead parents is enough to
send him over the edge grabs a sword and
slices the throat of Jean-Paul Valley on
the spot right like literally cuts his
carotid artery so he's just sitting
there bleeding to death and his response
is you did it Bruce Wayne you killed me
congratulations right like I knew that
you had it in you I knew you had it to
do what needed to be done you finished
what bakar started you eliminated the
last and final win and so ultimately
Bruce Wayne changes his mind and he
ultimately ends up grabbing a first aid
kit and actually actually suturing up
the injury of Jean-Paul Valley right
like literally helping keeping him alive
and so it's an amazing moment because at
the end of the day Batman kept himself
from falling back over the edge right
kept himself from basically killing
Jean-Paul Valley and so in response to
that he hands himself over to the police
he hand himself over the Gotham City
police department now the funny thing
about this is that Harley Quinn was
initially going to bust him out she's
sitting in the driver's seat of the
police car she's like we can make a
break for a Bruce Wayne call let's go
and his response is no that's that's not
what we're doing here right I'm not
making a break for it I'm not running
this was not some kind of a scam because
if I do that after making that speech to
the city of Gotham if I do that they'll
never trust me again they will never
ever ever trust me again this is bigger
than that this is bigger than any of
that stuff right Gotham City has to
learn to trust Bruce Wayne and the idea
of Batman believe in the idea of Batman
even if Batman doesn't exist anymore
they have to believe that they
themselves can make the city of Gotham
better and I can help them do that by
giving them all that money and so Harley
Quinn ultimately ends up just letting
him leave and so that's what's kind of
crazy here is because as that time
progresses we basically have all the
fortunes of Batman that are handed over
to the entirety of Gotham City right
like the hundreds of billions of dollars
at his disposal are handed over Gotham
City uses that money to retrofit the
Gotham City Police Department to make
them more effective they use that money
just as Batman said they would by
handing it over to schools by handing it
over to different places out there in
order to ensure that Gotham can
experience a kind of economic
proliferation from the ground up and so
one of the last things that happens here
is that while Bruce Wayne sits in jail a
guy comes out of nowhere and says why am
I here Bruce right and his response is
Montoya needed someone to keep an eye on
me someone who knows my tricks and can
stop me from escaping so I had her track
you down and this guy's response is well
we both know that no cell can hold you
Bruce Wayne if what you want to do is
leave you can leave at any point in time
you really expect me to believe that you
intend on staying here there's got to be
another reason you're right there is
another reason I simply want to talk and
the guy that Bruce Wayne is talking to
is none other than Jason Todd the first
Robin and the curse of the Y Fight Night
Universe with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you on later
peace